it's a pleasure to sit first of all with
you Tony here because I know that with
sing cup is coming just nearby and you
are so busy with many things so thank
you for coming first of all and now that
we are celebrating the 10th anniversary
of singfield cup um I mean it's
important to kind of make sure
acknowledge the the role which you
played in this tournament and um let's
say your passion to Chas your
organizational skills made it clear that
this tournament has high standards so
how can you reflect on this journey with
singfield cup over those 10 years Wow
first of all uh I found out that it was
our 10e anniversary of the singfield cup
just a couple of days ago I can't
believe it's been that long honestly I
still remember that very first event
with just four players we had Magnus and
leavon aronian against gotsky and hikaro
Nakamura and and for for me watching all
of these great players come to St Louis
growing the event from four players that
year to six the following year into 10
players making the sinkfield cup a part
of the grand chest tour um you know I
think I'm most proud of the fact that
this is Legacy building for the St Louis
chess club what the the singfield cup
has done for St Louis is establish it in
the Chess World um throughout history
absolutely but let's start from the very
beginning how how it was actually done
how the first one appeared and what was
the inspiration for the first singi cup
the first singfield cup we owe a debt of
gratitude actually to seil we are mantry
uh seil is a chess coach himself also
known as The Stepfather of hikara
Nakamura um seil has been a great
partner with the St Louis chess club
over the years and he was traveling to a
chess tournament where both Magnus and
leavon would be playing um we reached
out to seil and said hey we would love
to get these guys to play in our our
first singfield cup uh at the time the
name wasn't even the singfield cup and
so uh seil while he was over there had
the opportunity to chat with both
players and secure their commitment to
play so that I would say is how the
first singfield cup came to be wow this
really interesting I mean I'm sure many
people don't even remember how all this
happened and how do you see the
tournament grown all these years from
that event the first one until the one
we have today T SN field cup looking
through all of the singfield cups it's
interesting from the perspective of the
broadcast the Arbiters commentators the
the crew that puts the event on social
media coverage everything has changed
about we produce an event like the
singfield cup you know in those early
days it would just be a couple of
commentators in the basement of the
chess club a couple of camera operators
capturing all of the the footage from
both the playing Hall and in the studio
itself um you know and there were some
hiccups in those early days I remember
when the stream would go down and
everybody would be running around trying
to figure out how to make it come back
up uh I would say that that not just the
professionalism for the chess players
and and that side of the event uh have
improved over the 10 years but I would
say what the club has really done well
has set the bar for chess broadcasting
and chess um coverage exactly and also
we know that single cup is a part of the
grunes tour the big you know the big
tour and what role it plays in the whole
grest tour and from which moment
actually it became the part of it the
grand chess tour started in 2015
actually it was a partnership between
the St Louis chess club uh the London
chess classic and uh our friends at
Norway chess as well um so there were
three classical events that first year
no rapid no Blitz um the singfield cup
is the one event that has been the main
State throughout the entire Grand chest
tour over its um Bo eight years I guess
now uh so the sinkfield cup to me
represents um kind of the bookend of the
grand chess tour season it's a classical
tournament that brings together all of
the very best players in the world um
and the players already know what their
standings are from the rest of the grand
chest tour they know what they're coming
into this and they know how hard they
have to fight and I think that produces
some very exciting chess in the
singfield cup absolutely uh as a
technical director of the tournament for
so many years which challenges you had
during all these years can you tell some
interesting stories and some challenges
which you had and you had to solve and
you sold successfully I could write a
book on the challenges that we have
faced uh organizing major events like
these things you wouldn't consider
geopolitics the closing of canals um
delayed flights and weather in Norway
can impact a chess tournament in St
Louis I remember spending uh very late
nights and very early mornings on the
phone with the US state department and
embassies and consulates around the
world trying to help players get their
visas in fact I remember one story
specifically I was with Yan npom Nishi
trying to obtain a visa to come to St
Louis the US Embassy was delaying and
and he didn't have time on his own so I
went with him in person to the US
Embassy in Croatia to try to obtain his
Visa unfortunately we weren't successful
that time but I learned about a lot
about the Visa process absolutely I can
imagine you know I've been through this
process also many times but thanks God I
mean players are here and singfield cup
number 10 is next to the corner yes on
the next corner so what are you
expecting from this one this year
singfield cup I think will be one of the
most exciting because it has some really
interesting players in it guys like
Richard rapor um Yan Duda these are some
players that have that are right on that
threshold you know we see the Magnus
Carlson the leavon aronian the Linea
dominguez's these are players that have
been established in the top 10 and have
won major events themselves outright
many times I think this is a really
exciting time for chess because we still
have those established players and at
the same time we have these upstarts
that are really coming into their own so
I think this year singfield cup promises
to be a blood bath across the board um
absolutely but what about the most
exciting sful cup for you personally
which one was the most memorable so
there was a year that Vish and I played
the singfield cup uh and I don't
remember exactly which year it was but
driving into work that morning uh I was
driving just past the front of the chess
club and I saw Vish andan walking into
the Starbucks I have to admit I almost
crashed my car I was so excited I'm like
it's vishy it's vishy I had to calm down
and realize yep yep he's going to play a
chess tournament here pretty soon um so
that was really exciting this is funny
story uh probably the most exciting
singfield cup for me would have been the
one uh I think it was 20 17 where
Fabiano went 7even and0 in the first
seven rounds I mean watching that
performance and calculating the odds of
him doing it again and is he going to
make it in round five and is he going to
win in round six and Will he win in
round seven the excitement building was
was really memorable I wonder who were
all these people who were working behind
the scenes all those years can you name
maybe not all of them but those who
survived for for 10 years I think we
might have to roll the credits if I'm
going to name everybody because it's
going to be a long long list I say this
at the Opening Ceremonies a lot to the
players they have a lot of contact with
myself or maybe with Rebecca who's our
event manager um Kelly toll who handles
travel and hotels for the players but
they don't have a lot of interaction
with with the rest of the staff
literally dozens of people who make
these events possible from the front
desk staff at the chess club who answer
the phone and sell tickets and make sure
that guests and members have access to
the commentary to the folks that
actually produce the events the Kevin
Duggins the Brian Adams Marcus baton
that are behind those cameras that are
configuring the devices and making them
happen Eric arnson who makes sure that
the website and the technology is
working properly Leonard Otis who makes
sure the dgt technology works it
literally does take a village to produce
these event and we're really lucky to
have a great team exactly so my last
question like what do you think is the
impact of a sful cup for on the history
of Chess and the popularity of Chess I
think the impact the singfield cup has
on the history of Chess is
um still being made I think what we're
doing in St Louis is producing great
quality events we've done it for 15
years and I look forward to doing it for
the next 15 that's a great um that's a
great comment I mean Tony all the best
of luck in this and all the best for the
sinkfield cup which is coming tomorrow
thank you very much thank
[Music]
you